kriegt von mir auch leider nur fünf und
zehn punkte wegen irreführenden titel
ist ja wie auf youtube so da wird ein
video auch gesperrt wenn du in titel
schreibt ich bringe einen menschen und
dann sich kein test ist wobei man so
etwas generell nicht den titel schreiben
sollte hey leute was gedacht und
herzlich hey was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja weil
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
ihr seht schon die kamera können auch
klein bisschen hören und stoppt ihr seht
schon ich setze hier wieder in meiner
essens experimentier ecke also ich bin
in meinem alten zimmer hier bei meinen
eltern und hier hab ich irgendwie bis
jetzt nur videos gemacht bistums essen
gehen also genau an dieser position und
ich bin irgendwie letztens auf die idee
gekommen so ein format zu machen das
kann man halt eigentlich wirklich als
neues format machen und zwar werden ja
eigentlich täglich irgendwelche produkte
in deutschland neu auf den markt
gebracht also irgendwie neues getränk
neue süßigkeit neues eis und so weiter
und ich hab mir gedacht eigentlich
könnte man ja diese ganzen sachen immer
testen das problem ist nur wie findet
man heraus was jetzt gerade neu ist und
da habe ich ein bisschen gut und bin
auch eine richtig richtig gute seite
gestoßen ich bin euch das hier mal ein
und zwar ist das lebensmittel zeitung
punkt net was auch immer hat er werden
auf jeden fall alle neuen produkt
launches von lebensmitteln eingetragen
das heißt ihr könnt das hier sehen milka
kinder em eukalyptus hier so ein getränk
und so weiter pizza alkohol also auf
dieser seite findet man eigentlich alles
und ich habe mir ein paar sachen
rausgesucht die ich so vorher noch gar
nicht kannte und auch noch nie probiert
haben und heute geht es erstmal generell
um lebensmittel die neu auf den markt
gekommen sind im jahr 2009 10 hat er
wahrscheinlich habt ihr auch schon
gelesen natürlich kann man sagen okay
die nächste folge ist dann mit getränken
die neu auf den markt gekommen sind im
jahr 2019 dann mit eis mit süßigkeiten
mit brot wenn wir das für ihn
wahrscheinlich nicht so spannend aber
ich sag mal so da gibt es auf jeden fall
noch eine menge spielraum
ja wenn ihr darauf bock habt lasst man
noch nach oben da und schreibt in die
kommentare
unter welcher kategorie ich den nächsten
part machen soll getränke pizzen was ich
so einfach da würde ich sagen fangen wir
auch direkt mal an und zwar mit
folgenden produkt trittin hat company
treats peanut butter karamell waltz habe
ich vorher noch nie gesehen die wurden
gelaunched am ersten april 2009 10 kamen
die nie läden mussten mitarbeiter fragen
weil ich ihn nicht gefunden habt aber
letztendlich habe ich sie gefunden ja
also ich weiss nicht wahrscheinlich
willst ja auch so sein dass einige von
euch die sogar kennen werden also ich
kannte sie nicht deswegen immer gespannt
das ist eben wie so ein erdnussbutter
bonbons sagen überzeugen mich voll
dann kann es daher sehen das ist
ungefähr so marti form schwenken auf
eigentlich wie smarties nur mit so
leicht und erdnuss geschmack wenn man
jetzt ehrt muss gerne mag glaube ich
wird euch das gefallen wenn nicht dann
eher nicht zu 100% jemand der immer so
erdnussbutter und so ist aber das kann
man auf jeden fall essen ich glaube acht
sachen habe ich ungefähr gekauft ich war
dafür lockt eine stunde im supermarkt
weil das ding ist du musst ja von
abteilung zu abteilung um das dann
irgendwie alles zu finden und
verschiedene sachen zu finden die auch
noch relativ neu sind
das war echt schwer aber wir machen wir
weiter das hat man auch das finde ich
gut sondern ist geschmolzen milka
eiskonfekt kerzen wurde eingeführt am
ersten märz 2009 10 habe ich in der
tiefkühlabteilung gefunden ich habe erst
die ganze zeit bei joghurts besucht ist
wir dann eingefallen ist okay vielleicht
schmeckt hier
sie haben wir auch schon das produkt die
ändern ich so ein bisschen an ich glaube
die ägypter in der gleichen form nur
dann halt so ohne vanille eis drin leute
schon mal das sind insgesamt drei
verschiedene packungen das heißt man
kann die richtung folgender papier
deswegen habe ich grade franken also
wenn ihr eine bank gekauft habt ihr drei
packungen mit jeweils acht herzlichen
drin kann wie krieg ich das ding jetzt
hier raus ich warte mal das kann auch
daran liegen weil die jetzt gerade
hingefallen sind ne jetzt habe ich die
ganzen herzen zerstört ich idiot also
sollte die ungefähr aussehen wenn sie
ganz sind auch passen also meinem zimmer
ist es so 22 grad würde ich mal sagen
die lagen die jetzt zehn minuten und
sind schon geschmolzen die müssen also
sehr sehr kühl gelagert werden sonst
kannst du vergessen das würde ich auch
als kleines problem sehen wenn man so
was man mitnehmen möchte ist es halt
direkt geschmolzen und ganz wichtig ist
auch nicht runterfallen schmecken tut's
in ordnung
ich würde sagen wir können eigentlich
mal wieder punkte vergeben hier diese
dinger bekommen
8 punkte von 10 und die bekommen sechs
punkte von zehn überzeugt mich jetzt
nicht ganz muss ich ehrlich sagen dass
schwenker irgendwie so ein bisschen zu
künstlich machen wir weiter das hat mich
interessiert und weise neue kohle raus
gekommen am 15 mai 2009 10 die dose hat
glaube ich 79 cent gekostet
und was das jetzt genau sein soll 0
zucker 0 aspartam 0 phosphorsäure
natürliches koffein das kann ja nur
scheiße schmecken aber vielleicht
überzeugt sie mich auch vom gegenteil
des eigentlich wie normale cola schmeckt
auch so ohne spaß es ist die erste cola
wo ich sage l die schmeckt ähnlich wie
coca cola pepsi schmeckt anders nicht
schlecht aber anders aber sonst hätten
wir keine cola marke ein
die genauso schmeckt wie coca cola und
hier ist ja nicht mal zucker drin
deswegen wundert mich dass also echt
genial wenn das stimmt kann ich
eigentlich nicht viel zu sagen schmeckt
mir gut gibt volle punktzahl 10 von 10
punkten kann ich euch im film ja
grünkohl als nächstes habe ich marabu xl
cookies die habe ich auf ewig gesucht
ich dachte eigentlich die gibt's gar
nicht einführungsdatum haben hier den 15
april 2009 10
und so sind die aus also ich denke wir
haben ihre cookies mit dem geschmack der
ich weiß gar nicht ob es eine eigenmarke
ist aber die machen ja so so karamell
artiges zeug also sehen aus wie ganz
übliche cookies griechen auch so muss
ich sagen gefällt mir eigentlich ganz
gut auf der anderen seite muss ich aber
auch sagen dieses karamell artige und
das coupé artige passwege nicht ganz
zusammen also der geschmack trotzdem
kann man super essen probiert mal aus
vielleicht schmeckt besser als mir ich
würde jetzt auch mal gut gemeinte sechs
von zehn punkten geben ja also ehrlich
würde ich da ganz normale cookies
bevorzugen aber gut er kann jetzt auch
nicht zu sagen wie viele sachen haben
wir dann auch vier okay eigentlich jetzt
schon schlecht das sind wir der nachteil
von so essens videos nicht wenn man acht
verschiedene sachen innerhalb von 20
minuten probierte ich trinke eigentlich
extrem gerne kaffee ist jetzt ein neuer
kaffee herausgekommen
ohne zucker bin hat ihn nicht obwohl ich
leider in einem ziemlich großen
supermarkt war keine ahnung ob das
produkt wieder eingestellt wurde weil es
nicht lief kann ich mir gut vorstellen
dann habe ich mich richtig gefreut auf
die neuen für
smoothies teilschritt habe ich früher
sehr sehr auf bewerten sind
wahrscheinlich diese länglichen cow
dinge wo ist fred ein echtes werbung
gibt es gar nicht mehr
die habe ich ja schon ewig nicht mehr
gesehen das war so richtig kindheit für
mich diese werbung von fried die habe
ich jeden tag 20 mal gesehen und ich
fand es irgendwie grün also da hat
jemand wirklich sehr gutes marketing
betrieben die haben drei neue limitierte
sorten rausgebracht die so limitiert
waren dass sie anscheinend nicht mehr
verkauft werden das war nicht wirklich
sehr schade
dann habe ich aber ein bisschen weiter
mich informiert und habe eine solche
gefunden die letztes jahr gelauncht
wurde
und zwar ist dass diese hier friedlich
orange die lag nämlich darum so das war
irgendwie die letzte und das habe ich
einfach mal mitgenommen also dieses
produkt ist jetzt nicht aus dem jahr
2019 sondern 2018 wird ehrlicherweise
sagen sieht aber auch so aus wie die
produkte aus dem jahr 2005 also wirklich
ich habe von meinem dritten bis zum
zwölften lebensjahr bestimmt 10.000
frites gegessen
gerade der renner auf jedem
kindergeburtstag und ich muss sagen für
mich zu merken sollte absolut gleich wie
jeder andere auch direkt wirklich lecker
also wie gesagt auch wenn das jetzt
nicht aus dem jahr 2001 ist trotzdem
extrem lecker gibt von mir 9 von 10
punkten
und wir haben noch drei sachen darum
liegen und ich denke wir brauchen
eigentlich reich machen wir mal schnell
weiter mit diesem eis von häagen dazs
das ist glaube ich so dieser bällen
jerry's ersatz das war extrem pro jahr
hat fünf euro gekostet das eis gibt es
seit zwei monaten brownie macchiato bin
ich mal gespannt also wird
wahrscheinlich nach kaffee so sieht das
aus schon ein bisschen geschmolzen aber
ist ja gar nicht mal so schlecht da bin
ich drauf wobei also je mehr man davon
ist das so lecker wie also ich bin
eigentlich ein kaffeetrinker ich trinke
jeden tag mindestens einen kaffee und
ich mag hab mir sehr gerne trotzdem
jetzt hier die kombination zwischen eis
und kaffee kann man essen muss man aber
nicht also ich würde da er andere sorten
präferiert von mir fünf und zehn punkte
ist in ordnung kann man essen muss man
nicht mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen ich
habe eigentlich gar keine lust mehr auf
eis trotzdem liegt er noch ein eis das
muss ich dieses ding hier wird im januar
2019 gelaunched meine ich genau und zwar
haben wir
die op in avatar schon wieder hat mit
erdnuss er ist gerade irgendwie akkus
hat gestern mit den ganzen leuten mit
erdnussallergie die können ja fast gar
nichts neues mehr ausprobieren überall
ist heutzutage peanut butter drin
ich muss sagen das sieht eigentlich
schon ziemlich lecker aus drittes wollte
was ich probiere ich merkte wie das
eigentlich überhaupt nicht gut ist jetzt
weiter zu essen
trotzdem ist es ja lecker also die
verpackung finde ich weiß wir haben auch
drei ice für zwei euro darin schmecken
tut's auch in ordnung kriegt von mir ab
19 punkte
so richtig umgehauen hat es mich jetzt
nicht also wenn man das mag so
erdnussbutter und orio dann ist das
glaube ich richtig nass aber er macht
damit auf keinen fall was falsch mit dem
box habt ich habe jetzt allerdings
überhaupt mal drauf und zu guter letzt
habe ich hab gefunden
auch erst seit zwei monaten draußen nähe
doch schon am ersten februar 2009 10
wurden die neuen studenten gelaunt auch
die hiltroper also ich habe mich noch
nie in meinem leben so sehr auf
studenten gefreut als es entstehen
heutzutage kombination natürlich muss
man immer aktuell bleiben und auch immer
was neues ausprobieren aber irgendwie
toll mal dümmer oder ich es davon jetzt
ein
nehme man sagt ihr eine show hätte ich
es davon jetzt eine mal mehr kann ihn
nicht gleich das ganze spiel
ich denke mal langsam zergehen zu lassen
okay ich habe schon ein knallhartes
fazit erstmal es schmeckt in ordnung
kann man essen ist lecker schmeckte
allerdings 0 cookie und 0 heraus ist
schmeckt einfach nur noch schokolade da
hätte ich auch eine ganz normale
variante von dem zeug bestellen können
kaufen können kriegt von mir auch leider
nur fünf und zehn punkte wegen
irreführenden titel ist ja wie auf
youtube so oder wird ein video auf
gesperrt wenn du in titel schreibst ich
bringe einen menschen um und dann
süßigkeiten test ist wobei man so etwas
generell nicht den titel schreiben
sollte wäre ich jetzt deutschlehrer will
ich dran schreiben
thema verfehlt das wars mit dem video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen lassen
nach oben da schreibt eure wünsche für
die weiteren parks dieses formats in die
kommentare getränke schützenmatt mäßig
haut rein
wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder ich muss
jetzt erstmal ein bisschen ihr dessen
sacken lassen